we used to get an awful lot done up in
the united states congress we actually
worked
we had five parts of the deal we will
definitely sign on to this compromise
package
so long as you also accept this giant
pile of manure
that we've got right here for you that
we're gonna hit in the face with
joe biden came out and announced a deal
had been reached on infrastructure yay
okay so first of all let me just note
america's infrastructure
is not in serious trouble the notion
that america's infrastructure
is just awful and bad in every way and
it's just horrifying
it's not true the vast majority of
america's roads and bridges are
pretty okay and the vast majority of the
ones that are really not doing well
are ones that are in particular states
which means they really should be state
costs
not federal costs like the notion that
we have much worse infrastructure
than anywhere else on earth or that we
really need to
pour like a trillion dollars minimum two
trillion dollars
into infrastructure is just not correct
but
this has become sort of the go-to
whenever you are a member of government
and you just want to blow money
into things all you do is you just say
infrastructure because this is something
people
on a basic level understand right we all
sort of understand that the government
has a hand in building roads for example
because the roads connect all sorts of
different communities and so you want
the government to shoulder the cost
of what is in effect a non-excludable
non-rivalrous good
right we all sort of get that the roads
are at the very least a public good
right something that government does
we understand that the government
helping to foment the the placing of
broadband even
is something that that benefits a lot of
americans although if you just
deregulate it the truth is a lot of
these companies can pay for it
themselves
but we all sort of get the idea that the
government should be involved to a
certain extent
in the infrastructure project because
public goods are typically
again non-excludable non-rival risk
goods
in which private people sometimes can't
agree
okay so does that mean that the federal
government needs to spend
hundreds of billions of dollars right
now on this stuff in the middle of a
giant inflationary spiral
in which we have a shortage of materials
and a shortage of labor of course not
of course not but this has become joe
biden's big bipartisan push because he
figures that if he can get
republicans on board for infrastructure
then he can pretend that he is a
bipartisan president when in fact he's
an extremely partisan president now
they already passed fairly recently a
bipartisan bill
that was supposed to send a bunch of
money toward quote unquote research and
development
directed at fighting against china and
it passed with wide bipartisan support
even though again it is a giant pork
bill
this is another giant pork bill now
republicans if they had any brands be
like
nope not interested right because the
reality is that
you aren't going to spend a lot more
money than we would like you to spend
and if you're going to do that you can
do that on your own
i truly if you just want to blow out the
deficit for no appreciable gain
then you can just do that on your own
right make you use reconciliation for it
and if you want to break the filibuster
and you're going to have to do it
through the budget process because you
only have two or maybe
three of those per year waste a bullet
on on
this infrastructure package and let you
own it but no
we have to have the quote-unquote
moderate wing of the republican party
including people like susan collins and
mitt romney who decide that it's
important to lend bipartisan cover to
joe biden now here's the thing
they are being played they're obviously
being played
i'll explain how in just one minute so
according to the new york times
president biden struck an infrastructure
deal on thursday with a bipartisan group
of senators signing on to their plan to
provide about 579 billion
in new investments in roads broadband
internet electric utilities and other
projects in hopes of moving a crucial
crucial piece of his economic agenda
through congress
biden's endorsement marked a
breakthrough in his efforts to forge an
infrastructure compromise
but here's the thing it was far from a
guarantee the package would be enacted
both the president and top democrats say
the plan which constitutes a fraction
of the 4 trillion economic proposal
biden has put forth can only move
together with a much larger
package of spending and tax increases
democrats are planning to try to push
through congress unilaterally
over the opposition of republicans so
here is what biden is doing
and this is why these republicans are
just adults what he's doing is he's
bifurcating this package
he's saying what if we pass this part
here with bipartisan support
but i'm only going to sign the
bipartisan part
if you guys allow me to vote on
and sign this giant other package that's
the same thing as just putting it all in
the same package what are you talking
about
okay so in other words he's gonna get
pretty much what he wants and he's gonna
get the veil
of bipartisanship at the same time so
here is joe biden announcing we have a
deal
we had a really good meeting
and answer your direct question we have
a deal and uh
i think it's really important we've all
agreed that uh
none of us got what we all were that we
wanted i clearly didn't get all i wanted
they gave more than i think maybe they
were inclined to give in the first place
but this reminds me of the days we used
to get an awful lot done up in the
united states congress
we actually worked we had bipartisan
deals
we got a bipartisan deal except they
didn't get a bipartisan deal as we'll
explain in just a minute now biden is
using this
he again to pretend that he is a
bipartisan president with wide public
support
he is not he's got 52 public approval
rating right now
okay now that is pretty much the exact
same percentage of the popular vote that
he won
last time around right over the popular
vote he won like 51 52
he has not increased that he has not
decreased that it's a pretty hard
base of support but it's also a hard
level of support
on the ceiling so as things start to
accrue
you know as the crime rates continue to
remain high as the economy continues to
flounder more than it is soaring
as all of that happens he's likely to
feel some economic pain from
some sort of popular pain from that but
republicans are providing him cover for
no appreciable gain it makes no sense at
all
here's biden however saying i'm not
going it alone i'm not doing i don't
have to go alone anymore
i know there are some of my party who
discouraged me from seeking an agreement
with our republican colleagues
who said that we should go bigger and go
alone
to them i say this i've already shown
in my young presidency that i'm prepared
to do whatever needs to get done to move
the country forward
that's what i did with the american
rescue plan which is 1.9 trillion
dollars let me say this
when we can't we can find common ground
though working across party lines
that is what i will seek to do except
he's not looking for common ground as
we'll see
what he's looking for is the veil of
bipartisanship so he can ram through 95
of what he wants so mitt romney playing
the willing duke
as per his usual arrangement here is the
senator from utah announcing how happy
is with this bipartisan compromise one
of the big surprises i had coming to
washington was
the sense that while everybody was
fighting with each other you know what
we get along really well this group gets
along very well my colleagues in the
senate
we work together and it's been years and
years people have been talking about the
infrastructure needs of our country we
know that we recognize the crumbling
infrastructure and this group came
together and actually got a job done
oh my god look we got a job except you
didn't you didn't
quote from the new york times on capitol
hill democrats signed their openness to
accepting the initial details
of the agreement provided that their
moderate colleagues accept a second
much larger reconciliation package
so in other words we will definitely
sign on to this compromise package
so long as you also accept this giant
pile of manure that we've got
right here for you that we're going to
hit in the face with who's got two
thumbs and wants you to like and
subscribe